so let's generalize a bit what we
learned in the last presentation let's
say i'm borrowing p dollars
p dollars that's what i borrow so that's
my initial principle
so that's principle
principle
and let the r is equal to the rate the
interest rate that i'm borrowing at or
we could also write that as 100r
percent
right and i'm going to borrow it for
well i don't know t years
t
years
let's see if we can come up with
equations to figure out how much i'm
going to owe at the end of t years using
either simple or compound interest so
let's do simple first because that's
simpler
so at time zero so let's make this the
time axis time
zero
how much am i going to oh well that's
right when i borrow it so if i paid it
back immediately i would just ope
right at time one
iop
plus the interest plus you can kind of
view it as a rent on that money and
that's r times p and that previously in
the previous example in the previous
video r was ten percent p was a hundred
so i had to pay ten dollars to borrow
that money for a year and have to pay
back 110 dollars and we can this is the
same thing
as p times one plus r
right because you could use this as one
p plus rp
and then after two years how much do we
owe
well every year we just pay another
rp
right in the previous example it was
another ten dollars so if you know if
this is ten percent every year we just
pay ten percent of our original
principal so in year two we owe p plus
rp that's what we owed in year one and
then another rp
so that equals p plus one plus two r and
just take the p out and you get a one
plus r plus r so one plus two r
and then in year three
we know
what we owed in year two
so p
plus rp plus rp and then we just pay
another rp or another say you know r is
10 or 50 of our original principal plus
r p
and so that equals p times 1 plus 3r
so after t years after t years how much
do we owe
what's our original principle
times 1 plus and it'll be tr
so you can distribute this out because
every year we pay pr and there's going
to be t years and so that's why it makes
sense so if i were to say i'm borrowing
let's see do some numbers if i and you
could you could work it out this way and
i recommend you you shouldn't just
memorize formulas if i were to borrow 50
at 15
simple
interest
for 15
or let's say for 20 years
at the end of the 20 years i would owe
times 1
plus
the time
times
0.15
right and that's equal to 50
times 1 plus what's 20 times 0.15 that's
3 right
right so it's 50
times 4 which is equal to 200
to borrow it for 20 years so 50 at 15
for 20 years results in 200 payment at
the end
so this was simple interest and this was
the formula for it let's see if we can
do the same thing with with compound
interest
let me
let me erase all of this
that's not how i wanted to erase it
let's
there we go
okay so with compound interest
in year one it's the same thing really a
simple interest and we saw that in the
previous video i o
p
plus and now the rate times p
and that equals
p times 1 plus r
fair enough
now this is year 2 is where compound and
simple interest average in simple
interest we would just pay another rp
and becomes 1 plus 2r
in compound interest this becomes the
new principle
right
so if this is a new principle we are
going to pay 1 plus r times this right
our original principle was p after one
year we paid one plus r times the
original principle
right times
one plus our rate
so to go into year two
we're going to pay what we owed at the
end of
year 1 which is p times 1 plus r and
then we're going to grow that by r
percent so we're going to multiply that
again times 1 plus r
times 1 plus r
and so that equals p times 1 plus r
squared
so the way you could think about it in
simple interest every year we added a pr
like you know
every in simple interest we added plus
pr every year so if this was you know
fifty dollars and this is fifteen
percent every year we're adding uh three
dollar uh
uh we're adding was that fifty percent
we're adding seven fifty in interest
right where p is the principle r's are
eight in compound interest every year
we're multiplying the principle times
one plus the rate
right
so if we go to year three we're going to
multiply this times one plus r so year
three is p times 1 plus r to the third
so year t is going to be principal times
1 plus r
to the t power
and so let's see that same example this
is the we had 200
in this example with simple interest
let's see what we owe in compound
interest
the principal
is fifty dollars
fifty dollars
one plus and what's the rate 0.15
and we're borrowing it for 20 years
so this is equal to
times
1.15 to the 20th power to 20th power i
know you can't read that but let me
now let me see what i can do about the
20th power
so let me use my excel
let me clear all of this because just
actually i need to just use my mouse
instead of the pen tool
let me clear everything
okay so let me just pick a random point
so i just want to
plus 1.15
to the 20th power and you could do this
with any calculator
16.37 let's say so this equals 50
times 16.37
and what's 50
times that
plus 50 times that
hundred and eighteen dollars
eight hundred and eighteen dollars
so you now realize that if someone's
giving you a loan and they say oh yeah
i'll lend you you need a twenty year
loan i'm gonna lend it to you at 15
it's pretty important to clarify whether
they're going to charge you 15 interest
at simple interest
or compound interest because with
compound interest you're gonna end up
paying i mean look at this just to
borrow 50
you're going to be paying
618 more than if this was simple
interest unfortunately in in the real
world most of it is compound interest
and not only is it compounding but they
don't even just compound it every year
and they don't even just compound it
every six months they actually compound
it continuously and so you should watch
the next several videos on continuously
compounding video
interest and then and then you'll
actually start to to learn about the
magic of e
anyway i'll see y'all in the next video